what is the issues of the only thing it
was the practical issues and here I have
to go the ones always meant your race
and poverty the racial divide and the
poverty divide in America is huge it's a
gigantic problem and it's a problem
unfortunately we tend to view through
ideological lenses so there people look
at it and they say well that's a
right-wing solution so we can't do it
the people look at it they say that's a
left-wing solution we can't do it it
strikes me why do we have to be
either/or people why can't we be both
and people let me give you one example
the world of poverty Democrats tend to
want to spend more money on job training
and repairing the infrastructure of the
inner city this is a really good idea
this is desperately needed that's one
from column a Republicans tend to want
to spend money on propping up families
in the inner city and creating better
family structures that's a really good
idea that's desperately needed why does
that to be that I have to do it the
liberal where the conservative way why
can't we look around for what ideas may
actually do some good and not worry
about their further ideological
implications what else they complicate
the reason is because race is so low on
the agenda poverty is so low on the
agenda that with every issue we think
about how will affect every other issue
that's more important and that's where
we can't do thing anything out raise
your poverty because unless at the top
of the agenda and so you don't worry
about what happened to another issue as
a result you're not going to fix it
because you're constantly shying away
from things they'll hurt some other
constituencies
but there's another crisis also that I
want to mention um that's not amenable
to these kinds of solutions there is an
integrity crisis i think in America
integrity it measured the old-fashioned
way if you think of integrity as having
a sense of how one ought to live and
trying to live that way it's already at
people to focus on idea there might be a
right or wrong way to live I don't mean
a right or wrong for everybody to live
it's hard to build focus on the way
there might on the notion of your right
before they themselves to live they
ought to spend time contemplating not
just how do I want to live what do I
want to own what do I want to do but how
what I to live and I want to put the
question that way we're really good at
think of how or other people to live
everybody can do that really well what
about me what about other people how r I
to live we don't spend enough time to
think about that we spend too much time
thinking about we are to force others to
do that what we ourselves ought to be
doing and that I think is the first
question integrity demands of us Howard
I live and then trying to find
discipline to do that and that's
something I think is dying in America
that scent of a distinction between how
do I want to live and how odd i live
hey